what's coming next um Troy was just
telling me got a crazy new song that's
on the way yeah like crazy agenda Plan B
is going crazy everywhere like on
YouTube YouTube like 1 30. he got like
130k on YouTube right now going up that
John doing consistent number I haven't
heard it yet it's Plan B about
a plan B A Plan B pill or a plan B in
life a Plan B pill by the way both can
be true a Plan B pill is also a plan B
in life it is
has to get out of jail card right there
yeah yeah you right how many plan B's
have you bought over the years man [__]
I can't count I ain't gonna lie they
need to sponsor me that's why I made the
song
and why I made this song I hear you man
I've been trying to get sponsorships all
my life
[Laughter]
yeah yeah we need